[Music]
hi I'm Jason and I'm the product manager
for Google Cloud functions hello I'm
steren I'm the product manager for
Google Cloud run
we're here to talk to you about seven
new features in both Cloud functions and
Cloud run that will help you build
modern apps with less complexity
let's get started with Cloud functions
Cloud functions are the easiest way to
extend Google Cloud products with custom
code to meet your business needs
all you need to do is write a function
and deploy
you won't need any devops experience
and you can connect over 125 Google
cloud and third-party services together
here are some of the use cases where
Cloud functions are a great fit
event driven architectures help enrich
your applications by leveraging existing
Solutions and products some of which you
may already be using
they also make your applications more
robust by moving processing outside of
the critical path
if you need to process objects once
they're added to a cloud storage bucket
or build a single purpose endpoint for a
GitHub web hook functions make your task
easy
a lot of the data that your business
collects may require some massaging
before it's ready to be used or provide
value
Cloud functions are great for these ETL
pipelines and can transform input data
into more useful information that can be
stored in bigquery or other databases
you can also use cloud functions to
extend gcp products bigquery remote
functions let you add custom logic to
your SQL queries using any of the seven
supported languages including Python and
Java
our evolution of cloud functions was
driven by feedback we received from
customers
we've equipped Cloud functions second
gen with more powerful and efficient
compute options
granular controls and more event sources
more compute means more workloads that
can use cloud functions that you can use
cloud functions for
this is great when you need higher
computational demand
and with more events you can connect
more Google cloud and third-party
services together creating even more
solutions than ever before
finally more control means you'll be
able to better tune the performance and
cost of your function
it's true that cloud functions scale to
zero but these added controls help you
get the most bang for your buck while
they're processing
now you'll have up to four times the
amount of CPU and memory
there are two new configurations that
you can choose from
16 gigabytes of RAM with four CV CPUs or
32 gigabytes of RAM with eight bcpus
these new configurations enable new
workloads that you might not have been
able to choose Cloud functions for in
the past
we've also increased the maximum
processing time for HTTP triggered
functions by six times
many of you requested more than the 10
minutes of processing time that we
previously made available for your
functions
with second gen you now have up to a
full hour of processing time for each
function invocation
in addition to http responding to State
changes for gcp products is a popular
use case for cloud functions
when a state change or action occurs an
event is emitted that you can use to
invoke your Cloud function
these events can be an update to a
database row a pub sub event or objects
being added to a storage bucket
Cloud functions now supports over 125
event sources that's 10 times more than
before meaning you can programmatically
extend virtually all gcp products with a
simple Cloud function
bigquery is a very popular Google cloud
serverless data house warehouse product
you can now extend bigquery's
capabilities in seven languages using
Cloud functions
bigquery remote functions support
integrating with external apis including
Google Cloud Ai and ml apis as well as
vertex apis
they're also great for data scientists
who want to leverage languages like
python to analyze data
we know that many of our customers have
workloads in specific Google Cloud
regions this often means that the
compute options are limited to Services
also available in those regions
Google Cloud functions are now available
in 25 regions
this includes two new regions Finland
and Netherlands with more regions coming
this year
you may not realize but Cloud function's
second gen is actually built on top of
Cloud run
this means that many of the capabilities
of cloud run are available for second
generation functions
many of these capabilities are available
natively in Cloud functions API and UI
but I'm going to introduce two features
that you can use by accessing through
the cloud run UI and API
which we make easy to do
instance concurrency lets you reuse the
same function instance to handle
multiple requests
previously every instance could only
handle one request at a time
this concurrency is a really powerful
feature that can reduce cold starts by
sending requests to an already warmed
instance
allowing you to help reduce the cost
because you won't have to pay for
dedicated CPU or memory per request
just make sure your code is concurrently
safe and that you set the appropriate
concurrency value
sometimes bugs make it into production
and you need to quickly revert or you
may want to slowly roll out a change to
a small percentage of traffic and then
look for anomalies
every second gen function creates a new
revision for each deployment
now you can control which revision gets
what percentage of traffic enabling both
of the scenarios I just mentioned
easy rollbacks help you deploy with more
confidence
that wraps up what's new in Cloud
functions over to you steren
thanks Jason
let's dive into what's new with Cloud
run but first
what's Cloud run
Cloud run allows you to deploy and scale
applications fast and securely in a
fully managed environment
it is simple and automated
there is no infrastructure to manage no
cluster to worry about and it allows you
to just go faster to be more productive
the first thing to know about Claude run
is that it is available in all 34 Google
Cloud regions
you can also expect Cloud run to be
present in future gcp regions
Cloud run Services automatically scale
container instances based on incoming
requests or events like Cloud functions
you only pay when your containers
process requests
with Clarence Services you can build
public websites and apis potentially
even leveraging a CDN like Cloud CDN
you can do several side Windows pages of
course but also rest or graphql apis you
can stream with web sockets
you can also build internal services
like an internal website or API
a private HTTP or grpc microservice
and finally you can do data processing
either to process Q messages or even to
build event-driven architectures
we've recently launched Cloud run jobs
a job executes containers to completion
on demand up to ten thousands of them
and like for services you only pay when
these containers are running and you
don't have to worry about any
infrastructure
with jobs you can now do more data
processing on cloud run like schedule
scripts asynchronous background
processing or batch data processing
all right let's dive into those seven
Cloud run announcements
first we are proud to announce a
partnership with datadog around
observability
use the official datadog in container
agent to send logs traces and metrics in
real time to datadog
then we are introducing health checks
first let's consider the life cycle of a
container instance
there is the startup phase and there is
the serving phase
with a custom startup probe you can
customize when new container instances
are ready to receive traffic
using your TCP HTTP or grpc probe
can be helpful to load data at startup
or to wait for an async library to
initialize
you might know that by default
cluttering instances are using a TCP
startup probe requests are only sent to
your containers when they are listening
on a port
well that's something you can now
customize
then we are also introducing liveness
probes
a liveness probe allows you to tell
cluttering if your container is healthy
or not on a regular basis and if it's
not it will be shut down and a new one
will start
use a liveness probe to restart your
code if it has lost connection to a
backing service to recover from a
corrupted local state or simply to force
or restart after a certain amount of
time
the overall performance of your quadrant
service might be impacted by the startup
time of its container instances
while cloudrun tries to Route requests
to already started instances some
requests might need to wait for an
instance to start that's what we call a
cold start
is why it's important to reduce the
startup time of your containers
but we know it's not always possible
to help with that we are introducing
startup CPU boost
without CPU boost the same amount of CPU
is allocated during the startup and
serving serving phases of your container
instances
with CPU boost the container instances
receive twice the CPU at startup time
we have observed that this can cut in
half the startup time of some workloads
for example when using Java spring boot
security of the software supply chain is
top of mind today
this is why we have enriched the
built-in security panel of the cloud run
user interface with software delivery
Shield
showing information relevant to the
security of your containers
first it will automatically compute your
salsa level
salsa stands for supply chain levels for
software artifacts and defines level of
assurance for your workloads
if you automatically build from your git
repository using Cloud build you will be
level 2 as Cloud build captures the
source provenance and signs artifact by
default
then it displays vulnerabilities that
were found in your deployed container
images grouped by severity
and finally it also captures more
information about the build provenance
of your container with a linked with
link to the cloud build logs and the
exact git commit used to build the
container
and regarding security we are adding
three new security recommendations
activeassist automatically scans the
configuration of your clothing Services
looking for recommendations to make
it will now suggest you to use secret
manager if it detects that the
environment variables might contain API
keys or password
it will also recommend the use of the
built-in service identity if it detects
that you might be copying credentials
inside your container image
Cloud deploy is Google Cloud's fully
managed continuous delivery solution
well Cloud deploy now has direct support
for cloud run
allowing you to manage the release of
your container images between Dev
staging and production environments
and finally Cloud run Integrations
you are probably aware that from within
a cloud or encontainer instance you can
easily consume any Google Cloud API via
a built-in authentication system
for example to read and write data to
spanner or firestore all you need to do
is to import their client libraries into
your code and cloudrun handles the
authentication for you using the per
service identity
however some other services are harder
to integrate with for example
to use cloud memory store reddis you
first need to create a release instance
of course but then you have to know how
to connect to it using your serverless
VPC connector and you need to know
what's the instance IP address
we've replaced this with an experience
that only requires a few clicks or one
command
let's take a look
from the cloud and user interface open
the new Integrations tab
select redis
pickle cache size
and click create
that's all you need for your cloud-on
service to have access to a radius cache
another great example is setting up a
custom domain via a global load balancer
it previously required dozens of steps
to create the various load balancing
resources
well we've replaced this with a
streamlined experience
go to Integrations
select custom domains via Google Cloud
load balancing
enter your domain
and then net clutter and do all of the
wiring for you
the last step is for you to update your
DNS record and you're done
your cloud and service is now serving
under a custom domain leveraging a very
robust Global external https load
balancer
okay
and these were seven new features for
both Cloud run and Cloud functions
learn more at the links on screen and
feel free to reach out to us if you have
any further questions
thank you so much for joining us
thank you
[Music]